this week here on the interview on DW
garry kasparov possibly the greatest
chess player of all time he's still
dedicated to the game but he's also a
political activist and a fierce opponent
of Russian President Vladimir Putin
Garry Kasparov thank you very much for
joining me here in Berlin today and a
very warm welcome to to our
international audience here on DW now
garry kasparov I'd like to begin with
you the chess player and I'd like to go
back to your very early days perhaps
your first encounter with the game of
chess you were just 5 years old and you
it made a great impression on you I know
but it was a game that you weren't even
playing in yourself perhaps you could
tell us the story unfortunately nobody
was there to tweet this story so that's
why I have to rely on the memory of my
mother and very vague recollection of
what happened on that night evening
whatever time was in Baku I just watched
my parents trying to solve a problem and
I I was intrigued by the movements of
these little pieces and and I learned
most of the rules by actually following
their logic and and when they discovered
it so my father made a big decision just
to send me to the sort of chess group in
the planet Palace instead of doing
musical lessons as was traditional
family you mentioned that you grew up in
Baku in Azerbaijan which was then part
of the Soviet Union I'd like to ask you
whether you were a proud citizen of the
Soviet Union you did after all become
later a member of the Communist Party
look I grew up in a Saudi Union and you
know I guess many people in this country
do understand you know in Germany what
what it meant to be born and raised in
Econ in a communist country and I
definitely I was a product of my time
there thanks to the family of my father
my father died when I was seven but his
ankle and other
it's from a Jewish intelligence they
actually introduced me to sort of other
sides of the story so I could read a lot
of books and and let's don't forget from
age 13 I I could travel abroad as a
chess prodigy so that's why I had a very
different vision of of the world and as
former Commons party membership you know
it was pre conditional to challenge and
to - and not to have all the problems I
had to do certain things play by certain
rules but I left I left the party in
January 1990 so two years almost before
the collapse of the Soviet Union and I
was the first Soviet athlete who refused
to play my soul flap in September 1990
and played in the Russian flag again
Santoli Karpov in New York despite all
that I'd still like to ask you whether
you have any nostalgia for that time
back then I mean a lot of people who
grew up in the in the Soviet states they
do have not styled for that period
people here in East Germany do most of
these people they have a nostalgia about
their use just you know we were young
it's you know which is absolutely normal
but no the answer is no I do not you
know it's just I do I can't so there's -
I can separate you know my use you know
and and my you know first chest
successes and winning the World
Championship match in Moscow in 1985
three years ago with the Soviet system
so it's the two separate stories and as
a world champion you know dobe they're
young I joined the pro-democracy
movement and in in late 80s I already
you know try to invest my name and my
popularity as the as the world champion
in in this process you know in of
creating free at that time was the
Soviet Union but eventually free Russia
we're talking about the Cold War period
and there are a lot of people now who
are who claim or who believe that we're
in a new Cold War possibly and I guess
that you're possibly one of those people
certainly your new book which is out now
is called winter is coming and the the
the central message of your book is that
Vladimir Putin has to be stopped
why does he have to be stopped he
already did enough so I wish he could be
stopped earlier not to see the way he
destroyed the security system that has
been developed in Europe and in the
world after World War two
so set aside Saddam Hussein aside Saddam
Hussein and wait that was the next 1990
there was no other case of annexation of
the territory of neighbouring country
since 1945 and in Europe it's it was
unheard and it's very clear that today
Putin as every dictator reach a stage
where he needs enemies and since he run
out of enemies inside the country he's
looking for enemies outside and foreign
policy and aggressive foreign policy
conflicts confrontation has become an
inseparable part of his domestic message
okay so you've made your point
Vladimir Putin must be stopped you've
stated your case but the unfortunate
truth is that in Russia hardly anybody
is listening look that's why you know
pooses a dictatorship is so capable
because they eliminated opposition
Russia and even people who might think
otherwise I believe this it's quite a
number of them we still talk about
millions they are afraid to do so I mean
it's I'm sure in 1938 and 1939 and
Germany not everybody agreed was Hitler
but say you could hear their voices or
in Stalin's Soviet Union you know just
it's booting the dictatorship and that's
why I prefer to call him a dictator nor
the president just not to have any
glimpse of of democratic cover for for
for his power you know it's at the point
where they cannot afford any any
legitimate opposition side and my dear
friend and one of the leaders of
opposition Boris themself was shut down
in front of Kremlin mm-hmm talk about
person himself in just a second but I
just want to make there are many people
here in Germany who argue that we must
work harder to understand to the
Russians to understand President Putin
people point to the way that the
Russians felt humiliated around the
crumbling of the Soviet Union the
crumbling of communism a great Empire
which it had always been and that there
are many people in Russia who view the
what we call NATO enlargement they call
NATO expand
and that's why they're willing to vote
for a decisive leader for a struggle
steps up on solving my intelligence it's
not a well you can don't use what word
vote because vote assumes that you don't
have a campaign you have other people
you have you know you can raise funds
you can reduce your party in Russia you
can vote for Putin or else but so you
know do you not believe that there is
not a substantial body of the populace
but it does do bad it's relevant again
this is this history you know it's in
German in 38 in Soviet Union in 1952 is
this it you know it's it's useless to
talk about elections dictators are
popular because there's no opposition
inside and you know they they have to
step up with more aggressive acts
domestically and eventually
internationally to prop up their their
popularity and in my book I spend a lot
considerable amount of time talking
about the so called humiliation I mean
come on we just we can talk about
humiliation of of Germany after World
War one but Russia with all the help
provided by by by Western Europe and the
United States you know an eighteen
Walsman look you know it's it's if now
Estonia or Latvia would not be made the
members do you think that they could
survive you know 24 hours and after
Russian aggression these nations had
legitimate grievances and thanks God you
know Nader enlarged and protected this
these people who suffered a lot over the
last you know century from potential
uprising of Russian imperialism in
inviting intrusion
despite the all-pervasive nature of the
of the Putin government of the Putin
regime as some people would call it
people people like yourself you do
believe that an uprising of some kind
will be inevitable I've read that quote
from you but that optimism is
questionable surely when you talk about
Boris Nemtsov the way he was gunned down
in Russia it doesn't sound as though
there's much room for opportunity it is
you may call optimism or you may call
the realism based on my reading of books
of history it does happen you know
dictators like Putin could put details
like Putin's can crumble overnight or
they can last it depends
at this stage from the pressure from
outside because Putin's popularity in
Russia and Putin's sort of claim to
power is based on on the image of Russia
being sort of a fortress of goods
surrounded by evil empires that are
trying to destroy Mother Russia and
Putin's geopolitical defeat say Assad
goes down or else somewhere else in
world where Putin is engaged in his
fierce opposition against the free world
could dramatically weakened him in the
eyes of not just ordinary Russians but
Russian elite because the way Russia has
been run by touching over last year's
it's more like mafia the mafia boss must
look invincible the moment these is
inner circle smells weakness okay help
they'll take care of him it was once
said about you as a chess player and I'm
quoting here that you had a desire not
just to beat opponents but to destroy
them do you want to destroy Vladimir
Putin because it sounds very personal
here look I think we shouldn't separate
the game of chess and my activities in
Russia I play chess twin and when I
entered you may call me you play this
political battle to win it's not no I
play it was a moral imperative to the
killing of Boris and himself you must
want to win it so terribly painful
oh it's I also leave in exile yes it's
painful but it's just you know I believe
that you know there's something I can I
should do for my country that's why I
did it in 2005 I mean I I stopped my
professional careers to being number one
and I had many other options in my life
but I believe that you know I I had to
do that and I at one point at least to
tell my kids that you know I was
involved in the battle and I did my
utmost to prevent Russia from sliding
back to dictatorship we don't want
Russia to go on this vicious circle and
just you to be either repeatedly
restored as a threat to the to do to the
outside world to the country I won't
rush her to play a positive role because
it's still European country and
what's happening in Ukraine now with
many ethnic Russians joining Ukrainian
army to fight Putin's invasion I mean
give me hope that the russian-speaking
world would still be a part of the free
world and mainstream of civilization
final question garry kasparov do you
believe that Vladimir Putin wants to
destroy you yes or no I know that if I
go back to Moscow to be one way ticket
but I guess it's a yes
I don't know how how much he's willing
to invest in that but if he can reach me
I mean I I would be great danger so
that's why I left Russia in February
2013 actually following the advice of
Boris Nemtsov who knew that I wasn't in
danger at that time and it's very
unfortunate Boris didn't follow the
advice of his friends and he stayed
there until they they took him caracals
para thank you very much for talking to
develop anyone wedding thank you